a qué atribuye esta suerte de reticencia
por parte de Alemania a tomar una
decisión Clara sobre el envío de sus
tanques el leopard a Ucrania a pesar por
supuesto de la creciente presión
occidental bueno de entrada los alemanes
Siempre han mantenido quizás esa postura
más no sé si decir timorata o más
comedida con respecto al enviar
armamento Ucrania precisamente por el
miedo que tienen a que suponga una
cicate para la guerra y a ello pues
naturalmente hay que sumarle el hecho de
que las flotas de blindados leopardos
son limitadas al final es Alemania que
encontró la esa importante baza política
no dejan de ser carros de combate que
son la principal herramienta del combate
terrestre y por tanto los alemanes les
interesa mantener esa digamos es el Asa
de esa posibilidad política a partir de
ahí nuevamente el número de este tipo de
blindados es relativamente pequeño y por
tanto Pues hay reticencias por parte ya
no solo de Alemania sino de otros países
de entrenarlos ahora una pregunta más
concreta no sobre este tipo de que tanto
pide Ucrania En qué se diferencian los
tanques el leopard de los abrams
estadounidenses Y por qué quiebre los
considera clave en esta batalla contra
Rusia Bueno más que grandes diferencias
en realidad son dos proyectos que
nacieron a la par eso no mucha gente lo
sabe Pero leopardos y el M1 ahora sube
gente de un mismo proyecto llamado
mbt 70 en la Guerra Fría son muy
parecidos en cuanto a casi todo salvo en
cuanto al motor Este es el principal
problema del habla tiene una turbina de
gas que consume una cantidad enorme de
combustible se habla de hasta 15 litros
de combustible solo para arrancarlo
entonces para un ejército como el
ucraneo o para casi cualquier otro
ejército que no está acostumbrado a
lidiar con esa logística pues es
bastante complicado proveerla de ahí que
existe una clarísima preferencia por el
leopardos que es un tanque probado
exportado Un diseño Maduro que funciona
bien y que además no tiene esa huella
logística ese coste logístico que sí
tiene el M1 abrams estadounidense chao
como especialista en defensa desde su
punto de vista que podría esperarse
respecto de la reacción rusa en caso de
que se concrete estos envíos no hasta
qué punto esto podría suponer una
escalada en el conflicto
Bueno a mí entender los rusos como ya
hemos ido viendo a lo largo de la gran
hecho Bueno han tratado establecer
numerosas líneas rojas a lo largo de la
misma con respecto al envío de material
y el apoyo a Ucrania pero nunca se ha
materializado realmente nada concreto se
ha ido enviado cada vez más material no
ha habido una reacción rusa y por tanto
el envío de este tipo de material
Simplemente hay que tomarlo como parte
una tendencia una tendencia en la que la
guerra arrastra los participantes les
fuerza cabeza hacer inversiones mayores
en la misma pero que no tiene realmente
un salto directo de enfrentamiento entre
Rusia y la Unión Europea por tanto yo no
esperaría nada realmente